Hey there, I'm sitting with Puff, and
he is a Firebase engineer at Google who
will hopefully be able to help me with
a security issue that
I'm having with my app.
>> Let's try.
>> Yes, so let me explain a little
bit about what's going on.
So I basically have two issues
that are very interconnected, and
they all boil down to the fact that I'm
using the user's e-mail as basically
in place of their uid.
So the first thing that we do in the app
is when they sign up with an e-mail and
password.
I have this really nice
flow where I basically
use Firebase's reset
password functionality
to make sure that the user actually owns
the e-mail that they say that they do.
But I realized when I was writing
the security rules, that if somebody
isn't using my client app, and they're
instead either just writing their own
JavaScript or using a badly made app
of some other variety, that they
could get around this flow that I have,
this really nice flow that I've set up.
So I realize there's no way to
really trust that the user owns
the email that they said they did.
And that on top of that,
I've got the email basically
everywhere in the security rules.
And I just don't know
how secure that is,
how to make that secure
in the security rules.
So you are a security rules guru.
Can you help me?
>> That sounds to like a good challenge.
Okay, let's take it one step at a time.
>> Okay [LAUGH].
>> So the first thing is indeed your
e-mail verification flow, right?
Because you are using
Firebase's reset password flow,
which is great and it's a great use
of that flow in your Android app.
But the problem that you run into
now is thhat since the code runs
on the user's phone
in their Android app,
you have to trust the user to write back
their e-mail address into the database.
And that is where you now have
a security problem is that correct?
>> Yes, I mean if they're using the app,
things should be fine, but
if they're not using the app,
if they just write their own JavaScript.
>> Exactly, so and
this is what we see very, very often
with developers that are using Firebase.
You want to trust that it's your
code modifying the database.
But there's really, since Firebase
is a cloud-based database,
there is no way to be guaranteed
that it's your code that's writing.
The only thing you know is which
user is writing to that database.
And that's what you see with
the Android app, right?
You can verify that it's the user
that signed into the Android app
that is writing the e-mail address.
And you can do the same, no matter if
they wrote their own Android app or
even if they were using
a JavaScript client.
You can verify that it's that user
that's writing the email address.
What you can even validate is that what
they're writing is an email address.
You can validate that
there's a at in there, right.
You can validate the value.
But you cannot verify that it's
actually the correct email address.
That that's where you're essentially
losing the security battle.
>> Yeah, I mean we're doing
that type of stuff for
validating that it looks
like an e-mail address.
So basically what I'm hearing is that
it is either very hard or impossible
to do this kind of stuff on the client
side or with the security rules.
Is that true?
>> Yeah, the problem indeed is that
you must verify the e-mail address
in an environment that you trust.
And you should not trust
the user's Android phone.
So the only option there is actually
to take the same flow that you have
on the phone and
move it to a trusted environment.
And typically then you
think of a server,
right, where you essentially take
the same flow, and you run through it.
So the user, right,
you sent them an email with
a password reset type thing in there.
Essentially a shared secret.
And they can only validate that
they own that e-mail address by
typing that secret code into
some interface that you defined.
The flow is exactly what you do today.
The difference is that it now runs on
an environment that you can trust, and
that means that it runs under
somebody else's identity.
So that's also how you secure
this flow in the security rules,
is that you verify that it's
written from a trusted identity and
not from just the user that is
running the app on his Android phone.
>> So I really like what you're saying
that basically the flow itself doesn't
have to change,
we can probably use at least similar
code to what we already have.
The thing that makes me nervous
is when you say a server.
So how sort of hheavyweight
are we talking about?
What would I need to do to
set up something like this?
>> Yeah, and this is a very common
question we get them on firebase,
as soon as we mention
Running server code.
This is not your typical
infrastructure server.
This is essentially a trusted device
that runs to same type of code that
you would run on the Android phone or
on a web page, but
it's now runs in a trusted environment.
So you could run this,
I always say that a lot of my
maintenance scripts run in JSFiddles.
I'm not saying you should do that.
But since I don't myself run,
these are for
my own research type databases,
since DRs are not really production.
I just run to maintenance
whenever I feel like it.
But it is trusted, because only
I have access to these scripts.
So only I can run them.
Just like that you could run them on
a small Google Compute Engine instance,
for example, or on an EC2 instance.
And it can really be like this smallest
one you that you can get there because
you don't need to do a lot of work.
Or if you really want to, you could
even run it on your own Android phone.
You'd have the exact same code.
It runs on your phone and
since it doesn't run on my phone,
you know that you can trust it.
>> Interesting.
I guess I just have to keep my
Android phone on all the time.
>> Yeah,
that's the only thing you need to do.
>> So I mean that doesn't sound like
the scary type of server, I suppose.
But we're kind of already
in the thick of things.
Are there any options for
working without a server that could
still get us where we want to go?
>> Yeah.
This is going to get more challenging.
So this is where you need definitely to
add some steps into the current flow.
So right now the program that you have,
seems to be that you trust that if
two accounts have the same email
address written into their profile data,
that it's the same user.
And that those are the accounts
that you want to merge.
And this is something that
you you should not do,
because right as we covered before, you
cannot trust that the email address they
write is an email address that they own.
So you really must find another
way to get these people to
agree to merge these accounts.
So a very common approach
would be to actually put in
a mutual agreements
type of flow in there.
So instead of merging
the accounts like you do now,
you actually require that a use
proposes to merge an account.
And that then,
the account that they want to merge
into has to accept that proposed merge.
And since you already have your friends
list, you sort of have the mechanism
in place there to identify which
account you want to merge.
So you don't even have to rely
on the email address there.
You can also have them select the
accounts that they want to merge into.
>> Okay, so a lot of extra code
on the client side is in there.
>> Yes, definitely.
>> So besides adding sort of
bulk of the client side app,
would this add any kind of bulk to
the security rules themselves, or
what would that look like?
>> Yeah definitely.
You need to write some
security rules for it,
like the place where these users meet
up and agree to merge their accounts.
And I've written some examples for that,
to to essentially highlight
how that would work.
>> That's super helpful.
I guess we'll take a look
at those later, so